euromax highlights and here's your host
louise howton hello and welcome to
another euromax highlight show coming to
you from our studios here in berlin
let's start with a look at some of the
stories we have lined up for you in the
programme
scandinavian success two norwegian
brothers and their internet sensation
thanks for the memory new must-have
souvenirs from the german capital
and love is in the air irish author
cecilia ahan presents her latest novel
and we're starting off with what some
have called europe's answer to gangnam
style the zafiki brothers from norway
are already superstar comedians in their
home country but their latest jaunt has
put them on a global scale they began
writing songs with factual and comical
lyrics and the youtube video to their
hit what does the fox say had over 100
million clicks in just 35 days
this is the video that the whole world's
been talking about in recent weeks it's
not exactly sophisticated
have got something on their mind what
they want to know is
what we found from our research was that
foxes are really individual animals
and they do
very different things
so
they sound very individual a lot of
people people say that
they sound like females being killed
yeah i cannot relate to that song
because i've never actually heard
a female being killed
are already household names in their
native norway
their late night tv show airs twice a
week and is one of the most popular
comedy shows in the country
they shot the video for what does the
fox say in the summer mainly for fun
they never expected it to go viral when
they posted it on youtube but that's
exactly what happened within seven weeks
it had been watched by over 150 million
people and was attracting about a
hundred thousand new clicks every second
before they knew it illvis were in the
top 10 of the us charts
not bad considering it was only meant as
a joke
so beautiful
we thought okay let's just make this
song about something stupid you know
make the contrast produce nice with high
production value and let the content be
stupid
and come back to norway and say
sorry guys we had the opportunity of
life and we couldn't find anything else
we could have made a hit but we we
screwed it up screw up sorry sorry yeah
now what does the fox say has spawned
thousands of covers some faithful others
less so
but what's the secret of ilvis's
astonishing success perhaps it's all
down to one of the key principles of
comedy never try
too hard
it's like the cheap trick
when you don't have any better better
ideas really just there's an okay blind
guy driving tall guy small door ripped
shirt elephant has to fix with needle
that's funny
they're only in their thirties but baud
and viggod have already hosted five tv
shows
one thing all the shows had in common is
music
their riotous brand of music and comedy
has obviously tapped that zeitgeist
i think they're very good they are very
inventive and
yeah modern
different from typical norwegian
show-based guys so
like them very much
they have
great voices song
voices and they are very funny and
very bright very intelligent it feels
like we won a lottery but uh so now we
just have to see what can we do with
this obviously we love doing what we do
and if we can do it to
germany or to china or wherever in the
world uh that's fantastic at least
germany yeah this journey so
that's what life is about
to do funny stuff and this is this is
fun
their millions of fans obviously agree
even if their popularity still has some
people well
foxed
well from comedians in norway we move on
to another famous duo from the world of
comics asterix and obelix
these lovable ghouls are from a tiny
village that with the help of a magic
potion refuses roman occupation they
were created in 1959 by the french team
of rene gustini and albert odazu
together they produced 34 books but now
the baton has been passed on and we met
up with their successors in paris
the new asterix comic book is the 35th
in the series and a very special one
it's the first one to be written and
drawn by johnny ferry and didier conrad
we were thrilled to be chosen
but you worry about being up to the job
the bar is set so high
we don't want people to be disappointed
we don't want to disappoint ourselves we
are asterix fans too
the work process was very unusual
the agreement we signed had a
confidentiality clause
no one was allowed into our studio and
we couldn't tell anyone anything about
our new book
after co-creator renee gossini died
suddenly in 1977 the asterix series was
continued by his collaborator
illustrator albert
now 87 he hand-picked his successes
comic book history
meeting him was a pretty big deal for me
but he had a lot of respect for my work
and only suggested a couple of changes
for example i had set the story in early
spring but because the book is only
being published now
he suggested i set it in winter
so you get to see asterix's village in
the snow for a change
when uder zou announced his retirement
after having worked on the book for a
year
illustrator didier conrad was left with
just eight months to complete the job
it was tough
and i learned on the job
for
i had to really extend my visual
vocabulary
vocabulary
conrad and ferry's first collaboration
is likely to face some exacting judges
fans are very protective of the asterix
series set around 50 bc
around 350 million copies of the various
adventures of the diminutive warrior
have sold and been translated into 130
languages
the film adaptations have also been
popular
not to mention all the merchandising
from shower gel
to chair sets
and the asterix theme park 30 kilometers
north of paris
the latest book asterix on the pips
takes the fearless score to scotland
like scotland
and i realized that asterix and
oberlicks have never been there
in their day it was inhabited by the
pics
a strange people we don't know very much
about
so i could really let my imagination run
riot
in france bookstores are already bracing
for publication day the asterix books
are still some of the best-selling
comics in history and every new
installment is eagerly awaited
i'm curious and interested to find out
if the new authors have managed to keep
the classic style i've read every book
and i'm looking forward to this one
asterix is part of french culture and
needs to be kept alive
when five million copies of the 35th
asterix adventure hit the stores it'll
be up to readers to decide if conrad and
ferry are worthy heirs to the legendary
gossini and udazor
the word souvenir comes from the french
word for memory and when people go to
paris they often come away with fridge
magnets of the eiffel tower or even
french baguettes to remember the place
by
similarly here in berlin you can
purchase a genuine piece of the berlin
wall to take home for your mantelpiece
but beyond the overpriced mass-produced
kitsch that's available berlin shows off
its creative side with some decidedly
funky souvenirs
a mini herdy gertie that plays techno
music from berlin
a cake mold of the german parliament
or
a cityscape clothes hanger
these are just some of the 20 most
innovative designs for new berlin
souvenirs they were chosen from 670
entries submitted to a city sponsored
competition
this miniature berlin wall by christophe
fleckenstein stands and falls
it was inspired by the east side gallery
a remaining section of the wall painted
by artists
thinking about berlin souvenirs changes
your perspective because as a berlin
designer
you have to assume another role
i have to play dumb and pretend i don't
know anything about it
pretend i'm visiting berlin for the
first time
what do i see here and most of all
the designs for the new souvenirs are
now on display
berlin's government hopes the
competition will strengthen the local
designers ties to the city
along with the ever falling berlin wall
the other prize-winning entries include
a medallion that's an abstract map of
berlin and wall hooks resembling east
side gallery graffiti fashion designer
michelle michalski oversaw the contest
naturally says i
of course berlin has lots of souvenirs
but they're all the average trashy kind
you can get in any city
right now berlin is the most creative
city in europe if not the world
why not have residents of this creative
city create souvenirs which in turn act
as global ambassadors for the creativity
of this city
naturally the city's landmarks are also
immortalized as souvenirs
but the most popular ones include pieces
of the wall models of the east german
tribe car
objects with berlin's heraldic animal
the bear
and ones featuring the little men on the
traffic lights which originated in the
former east germany sales of these are
rising around 20 each year
more tourists seems to translate into
more demand for souvenirs
the range is enormous the demand's quite
modest
it has to bring back all the
the memories of you know being in that
place that's the main thing something
light
not too heavy and
some unique stuff in berlin
when i buy a souvenir it's of something
that's typical of the city not anything
flashy but something everybody buys
purportedly authentic pieces of the
berlin wall have long been on sale but
the wall is also featured in the new
souvenir designs too
there are pictures of the east side
gallery on rolls of tape and reversible
bags showing the brandenburg gate before
and after the fall of the wall
their playful takes on history
they are
is a trick to get a more distanced
perspective
laughing at something gives you a
clearer view of it
we hope that our little piece of the
wall will make people smile and then
make them consider why they're doing so
the designer and his agency received one
of the main prizes for fall of the wall
2.0 they hope it will later be
mass-produced
the important thing is that our creative
people the many designers who live here
took part and developed ideas for berlin
and that we can make something of these
ideas
compared to run-of-the-mill souvenirs
these new ones have at least one
distinct advantage they're definitely
made in berlin
want to learn more about europe and
european culture visit euromax on
facebook
you can tell us what you think and
you'll never miss an interesting topic
many euromax reports can also be looked
at again
there are behind the scenes looks at how
the reports and the program are produced
we like it when fans visit euromax on
facebook
the 32 year old irish novelist cecilia
ahan writes what some critics pass off
as escapist fiction but when you see the
delighted faces of her fans gearing up
for a good read you know that can't
possibly be a bad thing
ahern has just published her tenth novel
called how to fall in love and it's set
to be yet another best seller
a book signing with irish writer cecilia
ahern always draws a crowd
here in berlin her fans are giving a
rapturous reception
her tense novel has just been published
and looks set to become another best
seller
i think my success is because people
identify with my characters and my
novels um i write with emotion i write
with a full heart
and i don't write anything that i don't
care about i have to care about my
characters about the story and i think
when people read it they feel
they feel emotional you know people will
be laughing or people are crying when
they're reading my books they can
identify with the characters because
they're ordinary everyday people going
through ordinary everyday things that we
all go through
her debut novel ps i love you was
published in 2004 and made her an
instant star it was translated into 25
languages and snapped up by readers all
over the world she was just 21 at the
time
i was kind of going through what i call
my quarter life crisis so i was very
down on myself and trying to figure out
where my life was going and who i who i
was and what did i want and what was
going on and
and so i think when you're in those
moods i was very kind of introspective
and asking a lot of questions and trying
to figure things out and i was also
quite fearful of losing the people that
i love and that was something that i
couldn't wrap my head around
that we are all going to lose somebody
that we love
hollywood soon came knocking and a movie
adaptation starring hillary swank as a
young widow was a box office hit the
story clearly struck a chord
one woman's husband had passed away
and the following christmas she went up
to the attic and found to get all the
christmas decor decorations and found a
box of presents wrapped and labeled for
each member of the family that he had
organized
nine months previously and so there were
a lot of people sharing kind of the same
kind of story
the hearne's latest novel how to fall in
love is another bittersweet tale that is
likely to make readers laugh and cry
like all her novels it's set in ireland
it's about a woman called christine rose
who comes across a man on on the
happening bridge in dublin and he's
threatening to jump and with in the
panic that ensues they come to an
agreement where she has two weeks to try
to convince him that his life is worth
living and so they go in a journey
together to show
that life can be beautiful like life can
be wonderful if you view it in a
different way
as a writer cecilia ahern has never been
afraid to wear her heart on her sleeve
the daughter of former irish prime
minister bertia hearn she's not a
critic's favorite but she commands a
loyal following
and she is certainly prolific
i'm a very fast writer i'm a fast
thinker i'm a fast writer and so that
kind of schedule just suits me but i've
i've kind of made it work really well
for me i start writing a novel in
january i finish writing it in june and
then i edit for july and august and then
it's ready to publish in in september
october so that's kind of how my
schedule works every year
every new release by the irish author is
eagerly awaited
by young female readers in particular
a great way to relax they're very
escapist you can really immerse yourself
in the story and switch off
i always read them in one go
in a way they're realistic fairy tales
that's why i like them
i love the fact that they're set in
dublin because i used to live there
cecilia seems utterly lovely i can't
wait to start reading the book
cecilia ahern a successful romantic
novelist who knows how to keep an
audience under her spell
now unmanned aircrafts otherwise known
as drones evoke some pretty
uncomfortable associations but their
implementation isn't always for military
purposes
these remote-controlled aircrafts with
cameras attached make the best equipment
to film shots from above or in tight
spaces and that gives two cameramen from
berlin a special edge when it comes to
tackling extreme sports
shots like this are typically done with
computer animation
but these images were taken from a drone
the eye in the sky was developed by
berlin production company om studios
with it stefan miller can take pictures
that were once out of reach
street then follow a car and then fly on
over a house
of course you can overdo it but you can
also use this technology in exciting
ways and i think that's why so many
people are so fascinated by it right now
it's being used so often in feature
films
today the camera will be flying over the
bmx track in berlin's melo park
the drone is an octocopter unlike a
normal helicopter it has eight rotors so
it can handle the weight of a digital
video camera
innovations like this make it possible
to take such unique shots
one reason this technology is so new is
that the motors and high performance
batteries you need to build drones like
these have only been available for a
couple of years now
just before he launches the drone stefan
miller gives final instructions to the
riders
on the set he works with a partner
christophe dundas controls the drone
it has a range of 300 meters miller
works the camera himself
he receives the video images live over a
small antenna
concentration is imperative a crash
could be dangerous and expensive
the drone and camera cost a good hundred
thousand euros the rotors are razor
sharpening
the batteries have a duration of six
minutes so they have to be changed often
but for safety's sake the drone only
spends three minutes in the air
stefan and kustoff have to plan their
shoots well to get lots of new
perspectives and angles
on
yes
with a real helicopter you probably
wouldn't be able to fly this low
and if you did you'd stir up lots of
sand
to fly a helicopter a meter off the
ground wouldn't make much sense
this parking garage would also be a
no-go area for a helicopter plus at 4
000 euros an hour a helicopter can be
prohibitively expensive for the same
money you can hire a camera drone for a
day
and the octocopter is regularly booked
out the berlin company's customers
include some major hollywood studios
you'll never be able to shoot a movie
only with octocopters apart from maybe a
bmx film
it's much more of a tool that offers
lots of opportunities
you have to look at where you can use it
and how
for the dirt bikers the drone was
certainly worth it without it
the filmmakers wouldn't have put
together shots like these
in practically no time at all
and that brings us to the end of the
show for today but i'll be back again
tomorrow to kickstart a brand new week
of euromax so until then take care and
goodbye
you